what's going on everybody and welcome to
part 6 of the django web development in
python tutorial series in this video
we're going to be talking about
incorporating users into our web app so
to start django actually has a user
model for us but we could make our own
user model as well it's just that their
user model is good enough to get started
with so the first thing I'm gonna do is
Python managed PI and we're gonna go
into the shell maybe there we go ok so
now what we want to do is bring in the
user model so that's from django contrib
models we're going to import the user
model now we can learn a little bit
about the user model by just doing a
dirt user so here other than you know
the done ders and stuff like that you
can see you know coming down here
there's a bunch of methods and
attributes things like check password
you could delete although I will say if
I recall right deleting a user in Django
is like you mark it as deleted you don't
actually delete for you
gdpr fellows continuing along we've got
you know attributes like last login blah
blah blah
you've got things like their name you
can set their password what is their
user name blah blah blah there's just a
bunch of attributes and methods that
Django just has already done for us and
then if we wanted we could build our own
custom user model that inherits from
this model I just don't know that I have
any use for that just yet especially
because would you do that or like for
example on Python programming net
I wouldn't mind pairing user names on
Python programming net with user names
in the discord channel but I'm not sure
I would put that in the user I would
probably create another database because
not everyone is going to have a discord
probably most of the users won't have a
discord user name
so what I want a whole field dedicated
to that no probably not instead I would
have some sort of related database where
the user ID is the you know shared key
let's say between those two databases
but or not databases sorry
database tables I think that would be
the better way to do it so anyway you
could extend this or probably just use
related tables so anyways I think that's
really all I really want to show here
just understand that you can do things
like authenticate and all that with
their built-in user model so we'll quit
out of there now let me see I don't even
know if I left this it looks like I did
leave the site running it's been a few
days since I recorded last ok so the
first thing that I want us to go ahead
and do is you know if we want let me
just refresh this real quick okay so we
basically want to create first a
register page so let me also close these
we're done there so the first thing to
create a user we need to be able to
register it users so that's the thing
that we want to create first so what I'm
gonna do is come in to I'm gonna get I'm
just gonna clean up a little bit here
come on to my site main templates main
and we're gonna copy and paste home and
then I'm gonna call this register
instead and then we'll come over here
cool so what we want this to do is I
think what we want let's just delete all
this okay so now inside the block
content we basically just want a form
method equals post because this we're
gonna accept information the user is
going to post some information to us and
we're going to validate it or use it to
create a user in this case so anytime we
have a form you probably want to use the
following CSRF underscore token this
stands for cross-site request forgery
token this is just a certain attack
vector where people can trick a user
to doing something that they didn't
think they were doing so anyways if you
want
I put a link to it you can also just
google cross-site request forgery to
learn more about it but anyways we add
that to protect against that so we're
going to add that token basically every
time we have a form but for now what we
want to do is other than adding that
token we want to actually include that
form so rather than building forms in
HTML you actually just build them in in
Django basically so you put together the
form and then you just pass the entire
form and so it's like super simple here
you don't have to actually build it
yourself okay
so other than the having the form here
maybe the other thing you might want to
say is like if you already have an
account and then we'll do a draft loins
a login instead okay so other than that
I think we're good to go so the next
thing we want to do is work on now that
we have the HTML page we need the view
to point to the HTML page so we'll come
into view spy right now we just have
home page so now what we're gonna do is
we'll just come down here we're going to
define and we'll call this register and
then we always pass a request and then
we're gonna say form equals and we need
to import from Django dot contribute of
the forms import whoops import user
creation form so in this case user
creation form has already been created
for us we actually don't have to create
this form
possibly down the line we can add we can
extend this form but if we don't end up
doing that just know you can so for
example on Python programming net and
most websites it's useful to have like
an email well email isn't default
included in the user creation form why
might you want someone's email well if
they forget the password we need to do a
forgot password and if you don't have
their email well you're just kind of out
of luck so so especially on a website
like Python programming that where
people can subscribe to like plus equals
one for like a payment if they forgot
their password they need some way to
recover it rather than besides just like
emailing me and asking me to help them
so anyway that's one thing you'd
probably want to change I'm not really
sure why I feel like email is like an
integral thing if anything you should
have to extend the form to like remove
the email oh I just don't think that
makes much sense to not collect an email
but anyway form is going to equal user
creation form then all we're gonna do is
return return and we're gonna return a
render and request I'm not gonna say
request equals request anymore I'm going
to assume you guys understand I'm also
not going to give the template I'm not
gonna eat I'm gonna business I'm not
gonna use the parameters and until we
have a new one so the next thing is main
slash register dot HTML and finally
context in this case it's going to be
form because we're - you called it form
anyways form it's probably a good idea
to use especially in this case we're
like in this case we were doing like
attribute of the method or we're really
actually it's a object method attribute
all might be a method actually anyways
in this case you know you're just trying
to make a shorthand but anytime you're
using variables that are like directly
that's like a variable to a variable
it's probably a good idea to use the
same name sometimes I don't but it makes
debugging
hard when you're like over here and
you're using some variable name for that
variable and then you're coming over
here and if it's if it's the same it's
like super simple quick too quick to
find and understand what's going on
especially like right now our functions
are pretty short but in time you might
have a pretty big one in any way that
could get pretty crazy pretty quickly so
try to name it the same thing it's
probably a good idea okay so once we've
done that we now we've got the the view
the HTML template we didn't actually
really need to do the modeling because
the model already exists like the user
model is already created in Django so
that's fine so and in fact when we did
our first migrate you probably saw some
of the user and the admin stuff so that
was already done so now we just need to
do the final step which is controller so
in URLs dot PI so now we just need to
add a path to register and then when
someone hits register use dot register
and name mice won't just be you guessed
it register okay I think we're all set
so
let me come over here refresh up her
path register really pretty sure it does
what register music what am I doing
wrong here I feel like there's got to be
a typo but I'm like staring right at it
register register really are you sure
I'm just gonna rerun the server but that
can't be it
what No uh let's see my site mene mene
you were us up high oh my gosh this is
killing me um pasa let me come back over
here oh oh I see what I'm done okay so
it should just be register no slash if
you were gonna do register and then like
I don't know admin or something like
that you would have a slash or you can
have a following slash but in this case
actually I think we can get away with
straight register like that right but if
there happened to be a leaf following
slash I bet this hits an error it does
so instead what you would have to say is
actually register slash and let's see if
that should handle that and okay and
without the slash it's just like we'll
add a slash might be a good idea to
always like end with a trailing slash
except in the case here I believe I
don't think that will work for the
homepage let's check yeah okay so here
homepage don't have that but probably
always add the trailing slash we might
guess well I'll keep playing at least in
flask that's the way to go about it in
this case I'm not actually confident
that's always going to be true okay so
here's our form again we didn't really
do much and we can see that some of this
stuff like the the underlines and stuff
that's all materialized CSS you can
change that like the
I don't know how well that's coming up
on the video but it's like a teal
background or a teal underline or maybe
it's cyan it's probably teal though
anyway you'd probably want to change
that I'm not gonna worry about that I
don't want to spend too much time on
styling with you guys except this is a
little annoying to me we're gonna fix
that it's going all the way with a
freaking edge
yikes so what we're gonna do is go to
the header so templates hetero HTML and
for the block contents we're going to
encase this in a container so we're just
gonna say div class equals container and
then we'll come down here close that div
tab that over tab that over save come
back here let's refresh much better and
this is relatively dynamic so as you it
won't always have like that much space
on the side so say you're on like mobile
or something like that it does squish it
up pretty good the other thing we might
want to do is add a couple breaks right
before the block content just because we
might want to have like a break between
the navbar and like whatever content we
have so maybe that it looks a little
better
I said I wasn't a style here we are
styling we're done okay so now what I
want to do is this form is great but
there is no way like if I do this and
this let's see if ENTER works but I
don't think it would right there's no
way to actually submit the form
so also login probably should be bold
I'm just gonna fix that real quick it's
I'm not gonna style he said strong
and strong let's refresh make sure that
we're down good there we go okay so we
need to be here anyway
so we need a way to submit the form and
I'm trying to I think in this case to
submit a form all you would need to have
is a submit button so button style or
not sorry I think it should be is it
clap I think it's type submit I don't
think it would be class submit and then
we'll call I don't know
register button I'm trying to think of
what the let me just save that real
quick and see if we get a default but
yeah oh that's pretty ugly and of the
same password as before for I think
that's just a pop-up actually oh okay
there's a couple of things we need to
fix here but first let me fix this
button so button type submit' class
equals I think we can just say BTN for
materialize let me just refresh real
quick okay cool
so we could change this later like for
example you could say style equal breath
style equals background color yellow
this might make a pretty putrid yellow
whoa oh my gosh and then what is it a
semi I always forget on style yeah I
think it's a semicolon is it yeah and
then color will say blue that's good
enough I'm gonna let that slide for now
okay so now we can we can register it
okay so there's really only a couple
other things here the part of the issue
is our form is a little challenging to
quickly run through like most people
understand it's user name/password okay
we confirm the password we register but
for whatever reason password is like
over here
I'd like that to be on a new line like
this form is a little funky looking so
you could say form and I don't know what
the default is but you can have a form
and then it can be it has a couple of
attributes one can be as p1 is ah I'm
trying to think of what they are let me
hold on hold on look it's at paragraph
all right
so as paragraph so P for paragraph text
so it's as if everything's in paragraph
tags which is what we want so if i
refresh it's more organized now is it
it's a lot easier to quickly read so in
in web development there is you know
this someone could understand this form
but just had a quick glance there's just
something wrong with it and in web
development all these like there's like
little things that make huge changes to
how people behave on your site and like
the thing that makes a person leave your
website it can be the most miniscule
things and the things that keep people
coming back to your website it can be
the most crazy minuscule things and the
things that you think are absurd to get
like more people to like click a thing
or take an action the things that you
might think that's silly I can't believe
I have to do this but it does it just
makes a huge difference so anytime you
can make things styled a little better
like our colors really suck we've got
like at least three colors on this page
now probably four including the color of
the register button again that makes
people angry so even though it's like
super subtle and you think people could
probably live with it it makes an impact
on you people using your website so
anyway as P there's also as unordered
list and then as table we're gonna go
with as P because that's good enough
okay so now I think we're all set so
like what if we let's just make sent X 2
and then password P 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 P 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 and we hit register we see
nothing happens why did nothing happen
well if we come to views up high and we
look at register this
request a default request is a get
request so as we come through here we're
just handling basically for the get
request so the problem is this form
creates a post request which is a little
bored dangerous well in one case people
are just trying to get the server to
give them some information in the other
case we're trying to let the user submit
some information to our server like make
changes often with the post so what we
need to do now is make is actually
handle for the post request in our
register function so the way that we're
going to do that is form user creation
form actually I think in both cases hmm
no because in this case it's like a
blank form and the other one it's like
the form from the request so actually
this will just make totally separate and
what we're going to say here is someone
was complaining to and one of the like
the first video the text was not big
enough I've zoomed it in quite a bit but
feel free to leave a comment below and
tell me if the zoom is still
unacceptable I just hate making it huge
because then text runs off the screen
anyway if requests op method is a post
as a plus thought oh my gosh I even got
it right okay if request method is post
then our form it equals and it is user
creation form but it's populated with
request dot post so then what we can do
is we want to check to see is the form
valid so if form dot is valid meaning
things are filled out in the way that
they're supposed to be filled out so if
the form is valid we're gonna say user
equals form dot save this is the
equivalent of the dot save for the user
so at this point if the form was valid
so if the user doesn't it already exists
all that stuff we create the user so
form dot save save is the equivalent of
like model dot save okay so boom the
user has been created
the next thing we'll do is like if we
want to get the username which actually
we're not going to use that right now so
forget about it we are going to use
username at some point but I'll add that
in later so then the user is created but
generally when we register we would like
to also log that user in like after
someone registers we tend to
automatically just log them in it's kind
of annoying when you register for a
website and then you have to login so
anyway we can log in and let's come up
here I think we stopped it off so now
from Django dot contribute out logout
and finally we don't need it yet but
authenticate we also aren't gonna use
the logout login logs these are in
logout you guessed it logs a mountain
authenticate is used to authenticate the
entered password in the current password
which we also don't need yet but we will
so formed at save basically at this
point at this point there's no need to
like authenticate or anything like that
the users been created so we should just
login request user so now the users been
logged in now what we can do is return
and do I have a redirect no so from
Genco shortcuts import render and
redirect make sure it doesn't remember
face redirect is a way to force the user
or basically when someone gets to a
certain point you can use a redirect to
tell the browser uh-huh go to this place
instead so in this case once someone has
fully registered we don't want to just
like keep them on the registration page
instead what we want to do is redirect
them to probably the home page so I'm
gonna come down here and we'll return a
redirect and you could pass like that
right to get them to and actually
probably that not the slash but I
I'm actually unclear on that one I bet
the slash would do it anyway we're not
going to do either of those but I am
curious I'm actually kind of curious
because like two if you link to slash
that takes them to the home page but as
we saw in Django like URLs dot pie if
you say slash it doesn't correspond to
anything but that's only for the URLs
dot pie like if you go to this like
slash that'll take you to the home page
I don't know anyway not part of this
tutorial I suppose but someone can feel
free to test it anyway what's cool here
is you can redirect people to the
basically remember when we did app so
gosh we're even was that probably URLs
up high yeah so the app name main we did
that because I told you you can have
these like kind of dynamic or variable
names so instead of saying hey I want to
go to this exact URL address instead
what we can say is I actually want to go
to main home page so this these paths
could all change and they probably will
change especially if like in this case
they were not going to change because
they're our app but in the case where
other people make apps that other people
use the URLs are going to need to change
probably right so in this case they can
which is super cool so anyways we're
going to say redirect to main : home
page and that like I said will go into
you or oh stop hi finds the one that's
main and then and actually probably when
your web site is compiled actually I
don't know the answer to that one
because as we add more paths we probably
aren't going to need to restart the
website so I think it I guess it would
just always be checking anyway finds
main then finds rips home page send them
there which i think is pretty darn
awesome okay so alright so if the form
is valid we do all that return a
redirect awesome otherwise
if the form is not valid what we can say
is for message and in this case it's
formed error messages will just print
print form dot error messages message so
this is a dictionary this is your key
and we're just gonna iterate over all
the keys and get the actual message
itself and we're just gonna print for
now this is not a long term handling
here but we're just going to do it so
now we are going to basically in this
case we would actually just come back
down here and re-render register so that
should be fine
so I think we're all set let's refresh
let me make this big enough so we can
register we will make a sent Dex 2 P 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 and P 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 and
register don't need to save great so
let's check let's go into admin so that
user so it thinks we're definitely so we
are logged in authenticated as sent
texts to send texts I don't remember
what I made my password oh I got it
right anyway come in to users and we can
see a new user has been created they are
not staff will click on them we will
click on them okay we've got a password
we got nothing else though which makes
sense because that was our form cool ok
so we've got a user that has been
registered but now we've got a couple of
issues that we've already found first of
all like for example let me come back
over here let's go back to register and
let's just say that we do this in this
case no the user isn't notified as to
like what went wrong ok and then once
the user actually lot like registers and
they're logged in third they have no
idea that they're logged in so nothing
has changed up here
we just have we're not really informing
the user of anything that's going on yes
so so in the next tutorial that's what
we're gonna be working on is you know
basically allowing the user to see what
changes have been made and then possibly
will log in handle logout
we'll see if we just if we have the time
so anyways that's it for this tutorial
quick shout out to my most recent
channel members Richard Phan Harr saw
Peter and said here thank you guys very
much for your support as always guys
questions comments concerns whatever
feel free to leave them below text-based
tutorials in the description come hang
out with us in discord discord GG /
syntax otherwise i'll see you guys in
another video